ich habe mir lange gedanken gemacht
welches thema ich heute mitbringen und
ich möchte mit ihnen über in dem trio
sie sprechen es an der krankheit unter
der über zwei millionen frauen in
deutschland leiden es geht dabei um
wucherungen die etwa im bauchraum
auftreten und die dazu führen dass die
betroffenen wahnsinnige schmerzen haben
nicht nur wenn sie ihre regel haben
sondern auch teilweise im ganzen monat
die scheibe ins krankenhaus eingeliefert
werden müssen weil sie mit dem ganzen
schmerzen nicht klarkommen die
wahnsinnige schmerzmittel zu sich nehmen
müssen und es gibt obwohl es zwei
millionen betroffene allein in
deutschland gibt es kaum forschung in
diesem bereich emanuele marco der
französische präsident hat eine
nationale strategie im kampf gegen
endemische angekündigt in frankreich ich
finde dass deutschland hier dringt nach
ziehen muss und ich finde wir müssen als
gesellschaft viel stärker über dieses
thema sprechen ich würde sie auch von
meinem bekanntenkreis bei den damen rum
zu fragen wer alles in den rücken ende
mit riesig and ich glaube es sind sehr
viele und ich finde es schade dass wir
als gesellschaft übrigens auch als
medien nicht genug darüber sprechen und
deshalb würde ich ganz klar auch mal
fragen warum berichtet denn die bild zum
beispiel nicht darüber dass in wenigen
tagen 70 70.000 unterschriften
zusammengekommen sind in einer petition
für den kakaobäumen sie sehen sie sitzen
weil bild und wir berichten darüber
gerade in diesem moment herrmann wie
nehmen sie das wahr als arzt wird so
rüber da zu wenig darüber gesprochen es
gibt viele themen in der medizin über
die ganz wenig berichtet werden es gibt
immer die highlights über die gerade mal
gesprochen wird und sicherlich ist die
endometriose euren thema wohl ganz wenig
schritt und gesprochen wird ich bin
sicherlich da auch nicht der spezialist
dafür als hausarzt ist das nicht mein
thema dafür gibt's kritischer weiß also
dann die gynäkologen die sich damit
beschäftigen aber das ist generell ganz
viele themen gibt über die wenig
gesprochen wird und immer nur jetzt
gerade corona als highlight rausgenommen
wird damit krone auch so tun das andere
krankheiten das über andere krankheiten
zu wenig gesprochen wird es ist immer
die frage ob es zu wenig gesprochen wird
oder ob sie zu wenig im fokus der
betrachtung stehen und man muss
sicherlich nicht über jede krankheit in
ihrer talkshow reden aber man muss diese
krankheiten ernst nehmen und man muss
sie auch im kampf unterstützen das
entsprechende forschungsgelder da sind
dass solche dinge passieren dafür dass
sie im notorisch thema sind da passiert
noch nichts da verbessern wir noch keine
medizinische behandlung profis ganz
schnell wie sehen sie das
sollten endlich gedanken sind wir uns
völlig einig welt alles was so
krankheiten die untenrum sinn und bei
frauen und so weiter dhabi prüft
betreffen männer wir haben eigene sachen
oder kranke
man freut sich natürlich über so etwas
zu reden und deswegen ist aber wichtiger
punkt deswegen habe ich eine cola
aufgemacht und jörg ist es gibt ja viele
dinge über die wir nicht mehr geredet
haben letztens hab ja ja das stimmt
erstens zweitens davon habe ich noch nie
gehört ich also wirklich als man bis ich
wusste sie werden darüber reden und ich
habe festgestellt offensichtlich weiß
jede frau worum es da geht also jeder
einigermaßen gebildete erfahrene frau
weiß das und nun liebe frau
fdp-jugendorganisation
chefin das sei jetzt bewusst so die
forschungsministerin kommt aus ihrer
partei frau stark watzinger
der
gesundheitsminister kommt aus ihrer
koalition also muss ich nicht haben oder
krank bevor sie hier der ist krank young
hat der korona
später sprach nein das weiß ich nicht ob
er hat vielleicht eine psychische
erkrankung jedenfalls gottes naja dann
wieder geschlagen ist das jedenfalls
da sollten sie vor sprechen also die die
klagemauer ist nicht bild denn da sitzen
sie ja im moment sondern die klagemauer
müssen diejenigen die über vorstellen
dass uli jörges bild so verteidiger
herzlichen dank für diese wahnsinnig
spannende diskussion die wir heute
erlebt haben vielen vielen dank krieg
corona impfen meinungsfreiheit das war
für den nach acht der top der
schlagzeilen macht danke schön und schön
ab
[Musik]